YEN-JIE LEE: I
have been teaching
8.03 for more than
three years already.
So I was given a charge
to change the course
to make it even better than what
was actually done previously
in previous years.
And we actually made
a lot of adjustment
during this few years
with many other professors
in the physics department.
So what we actually did
is to change the textbook.
The textbook is actually now
much more theoretical-oriented
so that we benefit from
that for the preparation
for the other courses, like
8.04, which is actually
the quantum physics and also the
other courses which are related
to waves and vibration.
The benefit is the following.
So the students who are
equipped with more mathematics
background will also finding it
much more interesting compared
to previous years because
in the previous years,
we are mainly focusing on very
practical, problem-solving.
Introducing a more
theoretical-orientated content,
that can help us to
systematically understand
single oscillator,
coupled oscillator,
infinite number of
coupled oscillator
to where continuous
and infinitely coupled
system in the very,
very well-defined
theoretical framework.
And finally, I
think what we really
did is to introduce a lot
of demos, much more demos,
actually, than previous years
so that it goes with the lecture
so that people can actually
look at those demos
and compare to our
theoretical calculations.
And I think that is actually
evolving as a function of time,
and we were adding
or subtracting
the demos, which we think
is more useful or less
useful during the semester.
And that is actually what you
see now in the 2016 version.